if one thing you get out of this is the
thought process that I go through at the
end I'm actually going to arrive at a
formula don't remember I think the
formula not about memorizing the formula
the formula just makes it easier to work
with what you need to think about and
pay attention to is how I go about
solving like what's what's my attack
strategy so this is a hard question I
don't even know where to start with this
question so what I want to do is I want
to take question there's much simpler
see what I can learn from that and then
apply that so what I know is that this
is a large number and I'm interested in
what does it mean poorer number two
growing digits the answer is like it has
something to do and this has with logs
in your hand hopefully you understand it
better it has to do it base ten right
because what makes a number grown in a
digit right like here are the first
numbers that are respectively one two
three four and five digits
so when you look at this you think okay
this is about growing by factors of 10
growing by factors of 10 each time so
that should signal to you at least I
don't know how you seven you could but
this should seem up to you guys sitting
in the room this has something to do
with laws this is something to do with
growing at a rate of 10 right I am I am
deck toppling okay so the question is
like how fast am i growing in tens tens
is the like my grade scale that I'm
going to know so thinking about log base
10 is going to help us here right now if
you have your calculator you should get
it out if you try to click discreetly
when you get your calculator out you get
kind of some puzzling results because
some of these are easy in summer heart
now before I really get our calculator
all these numbers are all powers of 10
so if I take log base 10 of all these
numbers this should be simple right
for example by definition log based
anything of 1 right so I'm now thinking
about log base 10 if I call this end and
I think about log base 10
right log base 10 of 1 of course is zero
zero right because if you think back to
the metaphor I introduced to you right
something is growing and it reaches its
original size well I'm already my
original size 2 at time is zero if I'm
growing at this rate 10 times then how
does how longs it take me to become 10
times bigger than why I'm now the answer
is it takes me one unit of time if I
want to go a hundred times bigger that's
ten squared since two and then three and
then four
okay now this is promising but something
is wrong okay I'm trying to work out how
many digits I've got you right I'm
always off by one or is up a lot do you
notice that this is a one digit number
and the log of that base is zero this is
a two digit number and the log base 10
is one three digits the log is two four
digits okay so something is wrong I'm
off by one now I'm gonna push on this a
little bit more let's think about a
number like say I don't know let's speak
a number between ten and a hundred give
me a number between ten
25 thank you listen let's just do both
of them agree so now if I think about 25
and 50 okay that'd do it
don't give me an answer yet like don't
calculate it just think what would you
predict will happen when you take more
face ten of these numbers just think
about it per second
give me a number now what are you
actually getting me push
log based had a 25
the youth and 50
okay did it match your intuition think
about what to trying to do right
remember 25 and 50 we selected these
numbers because they are young
I've between ten and a hundred how many
digits do these numbers have they still
are two digit numbers right until I get
to 100 I'm still two digits but what you
notice is well look the log is growing
it it better go right because your think
about how long it takes you to get to
the bigger number now these will keep on
going up until I hit that threshold I
pass over the threshold to being three
digits you know glowing halos and
finally the Lord passes into a new whole
number so think about this right every
number in here right with two digits is
giving me log base one point something
right temper this guy that gives me
exactly one so therefore how am I going
to bring this all together
I remember we said there was an era
we're off by one do you remember that so
every time if you take just these guys
right and Wilf you want the number of
digits
one two three four five you always must
add one which boys at one now think
about what happens when I do it to these
guys right I'm gonna get two point three
minutes and two point six nine eight
double dot
now hold on a second how many how many
digits to these numbers half human being
these are both two-digit numbers so it
is not just that I round okay rounding
like this number like these messy
numbers I show around these numbers this
is close to the 3 / 3 digit number it's
got to get right it's got to get past
the threshold it's not enough to be
close to the fish on you've gotta get
over the hump to the next one does that
make sense so mathematicians have a name
for this trend where no matter what
happens no matter what decimal you've
got these we always want them to round
down to be two digits does that make
sense like even if I was to point no no
no no no no no in fact if you say what's
log base 10 of 99 what do you get
now again when I compensate we might my
off by one hair up right I am very very
close to three but I'm not three and I'm
not a three-digit number does that make
sense so let me try and put this all
wrap it up in a bird okay if I want the
number of digits in in a that's my money
clearly I need this logged guy here
right that's what's going to take me up
each time that's the thing that's
actually growing so I need log base ten
of your number but it's always off by
one but it has this error built into it
so I need to add one but that's the
model because I'm gonna get like
decimals when the vast majority of all
my numbers it's only these exact powers
that would give me a whole number so I
need to not just round I always need to
round down every time I round down right
in fact basically what I do is I just
need to slice off all the decimals and
ignore them okay so mathematicians they
call this the for function right
whatever number decimal you have you
just let it drop to the floor that
decimal just disappears as you can
imagine if you wanted to do the opposite
thing and here up they call the ceiling
function a function so here this is what
I'm gonna do this is my formula that I
finally arrived at as I thought through
what's the essential piece here the fact
that I'm off I have to compensate and
how am I going to deal with all of this
decimal guy so now I can answer the
question it took me all that time
starting very recently and now this
method is general enough that I can get
to them right this is just like a ruler
for misusing sequences this is your
amount owing after the entry payment
right you see now I can put anything I
wanted there so the number of digits in
- to the 1,024 is equal to and you
narrowly put me in this number and then
you reach your calculator and as you
type into the power of 1024 your
calculator just says just flip the table
of water because he can't evaluate this
number this number is too large for a
calculator but that's okay we know
things that the calculator can't just do
automatically that will help us what are
we gonna do I'm gonna use the power law
on time like this 1,024 can just climb
out the front that's the floor function
of a thousand and twenty four more base
ten - and if I'm remember this is ina391
fact without the full punches through
the nine point whatever and then when I
take the floor function 390 digits is
how many I have so like I said this
formula in fact this is out of the
syllabus but you can see its relevance
right I mean this this function it's
like absolute values hundred loads a
function exponential in motion the floor
function is not part of the series
however you can see why it's doing what
I'm doing right this is actually a
little bit like you know we do series of
sequences you try to pay off the load oh
yeah you cannot just round whichever way
is convenient you actually always have
to round up does that make sense cuz you
got to pay the whole thing off if you
round down even if you're closer to
going down you won't make the final
repayment right you'll still have
something oh it so that's why this is
relevant I just wanted to show you the
notation because the notation exists
and the meditation itself almost tells
you what it's doing